[Music]
Lucy gray
bear sing your way out of this one Lucy
gray what is that dress she's some sort
of clown
luy gray I didn't know I didn't know I'm
[Music]
sorry Mr
snow after every everything you've seen
out there in the
world what are the Hunger Games 4
are
[Music]
are the Hunger Games they're to punish
the districts those tributes don't have
a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not survivors
free we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
both
strange I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me that I was
still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect protect
people and it's essential to accept what
human beings
are and what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fed with the ter of becoming
prey see how quickly we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world your monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
back
Mr snow let me ask you one final time
what are the Hunger Games
for
hanging
[Music]
Tre it's the things we love most that
destroy
us
[Music]